- Leurs actions ont marqué
l'imaginaire des années 2010.
En Ukraine, où le mouvement est
né, et ailleurs dans le monde,
oùl l s'est étendu.
Des mises en scène, des femmes
seins nus qui rugissent leur
colère. Les prises de position
des Femen résoenent encore
aujourd'hui.
À l'origine, ils s'en sonprpris
à l'exploitation du corps de la
femme.
- Ça m'avait donné comme un coup
de tonnerre en plein visage,
parce que je ne m'attendais pas
que les femmes de mon pays
d'origine se rebellent contre
un système patriarcal.
XENIA CHERNYSHOVA, ancienne
militante du mouvement Femen
- a a a Tchernychevski a quitté
l'Ukraine pour le Québec à l'âge
de 12 ans. De passage à Kiev en
2012, elle est invitée peseses
Femen à participer à une action
pour appuyer les Pussy Riot,
♪ ♪ ♪
un a g g groupe féministe alors
condamné à la prison en Russie.
- Je n'avais pas réalisé
vevevergure et l'impact que ça
allait produire dans le monde
entier, parce que l'actioncococà
tronçonner une croix.
Elle a dû fuir le pays, parce
qu'évidemment c'est elle qu'on
voyait le plus. Est-ce que
maintenant les femmes se sont
émancipées? Je crois que oui,
quand même, et je crois que le
mouvement y a joué un rôle.
- Est-ce qu'il y a un lien à
faire avec la guerre en ce
moment?
- Moi, je le vois, je le vois
dans le symbolisme. Maintenant,
je vois que la femme ukrainienne
est beaucoup plus présente.
Elle est combative, elle est...
elle n'a pas peur.
- D'autres font la même lecture
de la situation, notamment cette
professeure qui s'intéresse
rôle des femmes dans les
conflits armés.
MARIE LAMENSCH,
Université Concordia
- Elles ont une voix, on les
entend, on les entend souvent
à la radio, on a leurs
témoignages. Il y en a certaines
qui sont partis du Parlement.
Il y a beaucoup de femmes dans
l'armée, proportionnellement
à d'autres pays. Le problème,
c'est qu'il y a aussi des
aspects de la guerre qui visent
spécifiquement les femmes, comme
le viol, comme arme de guerre
donc paticulièrement. On voit ça
dans tous les conflits
maintenant.
Elle, c'est Daria, la cousin
Xénia. Elle vient de s'installer
chez elle, à Montréal, après
avoir fui son pays en guerre.
Contrairement à X n n n n n n'a
jamais adhéré au mouvement
Femen. Au contraire, elle était
opposée à leur
Mais le courage des femmes de
son pays actuellement l'émeut.
- Elles trpopopopopopour se
protéger et protéger aussi leur
famille et leurs enfants de la
violens s s s s s manifestent
pour dénoncer la violence et les
viols qui se sont produits à
Marioupol et Boutcha.
(slogan)
- Aujourd'hui, le mouvement
Femen existe toujours.
Au Québec, les activités sont
sur pause, mais le chapitre
existe toujours, après avoir
fait les manchettes à de
nombreuses reprises dans les
années 2010. Le mouvement a
toutefois connu plusieurs
crises, notamment, les figures
de proue du mouvement ne
s'entendaient pas sur la
direction à donner aux Femen.rtu
l'effet d'un coup de sonde.
- Oksana Chatchko s'est suicidée
ce lundi à Paris.
- C'est une forme artistique de
protester et de se prononcer.- s
rangs des Femen.
- Personnellement, je vois Femen
comme un échec en soi, parce
qu'il n'a pas réussi...
le mouvement n'a pas réussi
à sauver l'âme des femmes
qui étaient là, à l'intérieur.
Le suicide qui en a quand même
guetté plus d'une et qui a
emporté Oksana, tout ça, ça me
rend triste. Ça me rend
énormément triste. Et je pense
que, entre autres, même dans
ma propre famille, avec mes
proches, c'est tabou et c'est...
j'ai honte d'en parler
maintenant.
- Pourquoi?
- onononononononon ma famille,
ça n'a rien apporté de bon.
- Le regard de Xenia et de sa
cousine sont maintenant tournés.
- J'essaie de croire que ça
prendra fin bientôt et que nous
po c c c c c c c c chez nous.
Mais des fois, c'est difficile
de croire que tout ira bien.
Daria ne sait pas encore quand
et si elle pourra retourner chez
elle, à Kiev. En attendant,
elle se posera chez sa cousine
à Montréal et tentera elle aussi
d'aider à sa façon ses
compatriotes